more terrible advice what else we got my
husband and I recently changed something
in our communication and let me tell you
it has changed everything our new house
rule is every time that you have some
constructive criticism for the other
person you have to lead with two
positive reinforcing comments one has to
be physical and one has to be mental
this small change in our communication
has drastically changed the dynamic of
everything so I hope this helps first of
all that's a trap man to begin with when
your wife comes to you and says oh no I
can say constructive criticism but just
say something positive first that's not
it's not going to work in practice
because you could you could lead with 50
things you like about them you could
spend an hour listing honey this is what
I love about you and then just been an
hour listing so as soon as you get to
the bad thing that's all that's that's
the headline right there and all the
other stuff
to paids okay to evaporate so just don't
believe that in the first place and then
on the other end of it as a man I don't
want that I know the setup just get